welcome to the presentation on i and
imaginary numbers so let me just start
out with a definition
i
is equal to
the square root
of negative one
or to view it another way you could say
that i
squared
is equal to negative 1.
now why is this special well we knew
that or we've learned that any number
when you square it is equal to a
positive number right if i had a
negative 1 times negative 1 that equals
positive 1. you don't have to write the
positive every time but that equals
positive 1. and so does 1 times 1. that
equals positive 1.
so if we think about this the square
root of a number um so far all we've
learned is taking the square roots of
positive numbers and that makes sense to
us because
the the
the notion of a square root of a
negative number didn't really exist
until now
so what we've done is if we've set this
definition that the number i and i isn't
a variable it's an actual number
it its value is equal to the square root
of negative 1.
now i won't go into all of the the
philosophical musings about whether
i the number i or or any imaginary
numbers actually exist i mean
maybe i'll make another presentation on
that but they exist enough to be very
useful to uh uh many engineers and
physicists so i'll leave you with that
and i'll i'll also uh
well i'll just hint at at uh well i
won't go into the whole e to the i pi
equals negative one but uh
that that blows my mind but i won't go
to that end and when you think about
whether i really exist you should also
think about whether anything really
exists
well anyway so so i i've diverged for
too long so let's cut back to what i was
saying before i is equal to the square
root of negative 1 and i squared equals
negative 1. so let's think about the
implications of this
if i were to say
well i to the first power
just like anything else is equal to
itself right
i
squared
i've already said using
this definition
i squared is equal to negative one
i to the third power well that would
just equal i squared times i right
and i squared is negative 1 so it'd be
negative 1 times i
and that just equals negative i
right
and i
to the fourth
would equal
i to the third times i
right i'm just using my exponent rules
here well i to the third is negative i
times
i right i to the third is negative i and
then we just kept that i
well what's negative i times i well
that's the same thing as negative 1
times
i times i right
and what's i times i
well definition i times i i squared is
equal to negative one so that equals
negative one times negative one
which equals one
interesting let me clean this up a
little bit
so actually let me start with i to the
zeroth power i to the zero power well we
know anything to the zero power is equal
to one so we'll
keep that that still equals one
i to the first power
is equal to i
i squared by definition is equal to
negative one
i to the third power
i just showed you is equal to
negative i and that makes sense because
that's just i squared times i and i to
the fourth power
equaled one again
and if i did i to the fifth power
well that's just equal to
i to the fourth power times i
right
let me i'll write that down i to the 4th
times i that's the times
i to the 4th is equal to 1
right this is equal to 1. so 1 times i
is equal to i
do you see a pattern here
i to the 0 to the power equals 1 i to
the negative 1 power equals i i to the
squared power i squared equals negative
i third i to the third power equals
negative i
i to the fourth equals one again
so i to the fourth equals i to the zero
and i to the one
power is equal to i to the fifth
i think you'll find out that
i to the zero and you could try this out
if you don't believe me i to the zero is
equal to i to the fourth which equals i
to the eighth
which equals i to the twelfth i think
you see the pattern any either any
multiple of four
equals one
and i to the first equals
i to the fifth
equals
i to the ninth equals i the thirteenth
equals i
so that's i to any power
i to any power that is a multiple of
four plus one right because 5 is equal
to 4 plus 1 9 is equal to 8 plus 1. and
we could do a similar pattern i squared
is equal to i to the sixth is equal to i
to the
10th
and so on and that equals negative one
and finally i to the third
is equal to i to the seventh which
equals i to the eleventh
and so on
equals
negative i
so why is this useful we see a pattern
it's a cycle of four and and so in this
pattern
if we look at this we can use this to
determine what i to any power is so if i
were to ask you what i
to the hundredth power is
well you could just work it out you
could say well that's just equal to i
times i to the 99th and so far so down
but if we use the cycle we see that
hundred is a multiple of four right
four times 25 is a hundred
so out of the 100 will fall into this
category this first one it's a multiple
four so we know that i to the hundredth
power is equal to one
similarly if i said i to the hundred and
one power
that's going to equal i right because
that equals a hundred
plus one so it puts you into this
category it equals a multiple of four
hundred is a multiple of four and 101 is
a multiple four
plus one
i to the hundred and second power
similarly
would equal negative one
i to the hundred and third power
would equal negative i
i hope you understand what i'm doing
here and all i did is i kept i defined i
as the square root of negative one and
then i kept multiplying i to figure out
a pattern i said i to the zero equals
one i to the first equals i
i squared equals negative one i to the
third equals negative i and then i to
the fourth equaled one again and then
the pattern repeated itself and then i
used that pattern to be able to figure
out i to any power even it's a very high
number
so very simple way to think about it is
if i had i to the 323
what i do is i say if i were to divide 4
into 323
what's the remainder
well i know 4 4 goes into 320 right 4
times 80 is 320
so i know that when i divide 4 into 323
so
goes into 323
80 times with a remainder of 3 right
and the remainder is what we care about
and this number is actually called the
modulus
and maybe i'll do another module on
modulus it's very important in actually
in computer programming
but since we know that when you divide
this exponent by 4 the remainder is 3 we
can say that this is the same thing as i
to the third
which we've learned is negative i
similarly if i said i to the 500
and second power well i know 500 is
divisible by 4 right 4 times 125 is 500
so the remainder is 2 if i were to
divide it by 4. so i could say that this
is the same thing as i squared
and i squared we learned by definition
is negative 1.
if i were to ask you i to the
37 we know 36 is divisible by 4.
so the remainder is 1.
so it would be i to the 1 which equals i
hopefully that gives you an indication
of what i is it might have been
confusing the first time because we're
dealing with a number that's quote
unquote imaginary and i'm teaching you
the cycle property of it
what you might want to do is review the
video again but then after that you
could just try the module on i which
essentially just keeps working you
through this type of problem i hope you
have fun bye